miel d'été de printemps de fleurs pâte à
tartiner pain d'épices pour cette
nouvelle édition de la Fête du miel le
produit était décliné sous toutes ses
formes avec une provenance locale de
quoi ravir les visiteurs les plus
gourmands pour ce premier weekend
d'octobre châtaignier je pensais pas
qu'il y avait du miel de châtaignier et
puis j'ai découvert les abeilles noires
que je connaissais pas non plus c'est la
première fois qu'on vient et c'est
plutôt sympa en plus on peut goûter à
plein de sortes de miel donc ça c'est
plutôt très bien je suis amateur de miel
j'aime bien j'en mange au quotidien
surtout j'ai un ami qui nous a proposé
il vient d'acheter une ruche donc il
s'intéresse un peu à tout ce qui
apiculture une 29e édition placée sous
le signe de la gourmandise mais aussi de
la sensibilisation leur jaune n'est pas
qu'un produit de bouche des petites
astuces écologiques et durables étaient
prodigués et là vous avez
une
un support qui vous permet d'emballer
des sandwichs de mettre au dessus d'une
tarte de mettre au dessus d'un d'un
saladier au dessus d'un bol pour
conserver les aliments et éviter
l'utilisation de films et de films
aluminium nous sommes dans une région
relativement privilégiée en termes de
pollution aussi on est dégagé de tout
sites de production et de fabrication
donc nous avons ce privilège d'avoir des
produits d'exception en termes de
pollution et en termes de produits
certifié bio alors explique que c'est
mieux par exemple d'avoir plusieurs
ruchers à différents endroits plutôt que
un rucher énorme dans les champs et
produire en masse en masse et couper son
miel avec du sucre en 2021 près de 20
000 tonnes de miel ont été produites en
France c'est 10 000 tonnes de moins que
l'année précédente